[Musique]
quelles sont magnifiques
alexandre da costa est un stradivarius
qui vaut entre 5 et 20 millions de
dollars c'est beaucoup d'argent mais est
ce que ça vaut le coup moi je trouve que
ça vaut le coup bien sûr que musicien
c'est un instrument qui a vécu des
siècles de l'histoire
leye dans mes mains je peux partager
vraiment la musique qui sort de cet
objet absolument fabuleux avec tout le
public donc je suis très très heureux et
oui moi je trouve que ça vaut la peine
vous n'êtes pas trop des revues de le
laisser comme ça un tel instrument mais
c'est sûr qu'il fait partie de ma vie
quotidienne donc je vis avec
l'instrument de manière naturelle mais
j'ai toujours le coin de l'oeil qui
vérifie bien qu'on peut laisser sur le
piano france que oui alexandre da costa
vous allez bientôt avoir 40 ans mais
j'ai commencé à jouer très jeune premier
concert à l'âge de 9 ans protégé de
charles dutoit et aujourd'hui vous êtes
une rock star dans le monde de la
musique classique
à quoi ressemble votre quotidien dans
mon ami mais c'est assez occupés ça
c'est sûr et je pense c'est là où est ce
que je me sens le mieux lorsque j'ai
beaucoup de projets en même temps qu'ils
roulent je me sens que je peux vraiment
mais m'épanouir
mais j'ai toussé tournée là je donc
juste constamment dans un avion là je
reviens de trois semaines et demie en
amérique du sud à bogota je m'en vais
dans quelques jours après tout les
premières qui se passe en ce moment et
je m'en vais pour l'espagne ensuite les
états unis je me rends en australie
ensuite je revis pourquoi quatre jours
ici je repars pour l'australie c'est un
petit peu fou vite famille aussi c'est
parfois difficile ou déchira plutôt
d'avoir à partir et laisser mon fils et
ma femme un peu seul derrière donc ceci
c'est le revers de la médaille mais je
dois avouer que lorsque je suis en
tournée puis je peux donner le mont 100%
et puis sur scène je vis vraiment seul
vous êtes un musicien classique mais sur
votre 25e album solo vous versez dans le
classique rock
[Musique]
avez vous vendu votre rang mondial tout
à fait car c'est ça c'est fait il ya
très longtemps et ça ce n'est que le
résultat ou le coming out plus ou moins
de mon processus artistique et créatif
on vous voit sur une moto avec du cru
aussi ma moto qui s'aimait vêtements
donc bien mais c'est vraiment sur jc oui
c'est ça on est loin lors que sa feuille
de montréal avec le costume est tout oui
mais justement cet album se veut je suis
affranchi sur cet album j'ai j'ai décidé
de proposer quelque chose qui soit
complètement libre
même si dans mon milieu classique
c'est moins bien vu si on peut dire
pendant de très longues années je dois
dire aussi que je me suis plié à l'image
que la musique classique impose à ses
heures à ses membres si on peut dire
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé que j'allais
faire un disque qui me fait plaisir
il va y avoir certainement des
commentaires qu'ils soient positifs ou
négatifs ou contre pau mais c'est pas un
moment important parce qu'il est
important c'est la créativité
l'album il est ce qui laisse a pris deux
ans pour moi à le faire donc j'ai pensé
longtemps c'est pas un coup de tête j'ai
pas voulu faire un acte de rébellion
j'ai voulu faire quelque chose qui me
plaît c'est justement comme et garde
finalement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après toutes ces années ces milliers
d'heures de répétitions avoue blessés
parfois au cou thorax avec votre
instrument est ce que ça demeure encore
une passion c'est devenu un travail avec
le temps nos peines nos game moi je dis
j'aime ça souffrir un peu pour l'art
parce que c'est physique ce que je fais
j'ai lu aujourd'hui je suis un ouvrier
de la musique moi je joue de la musique
je ne suis pas je suis en partie
peut-être un intellectuel mais en partie
beaucoup moindre que que celui d'être un
gars manuel donc pour moi c'est
important de savoir que mes muscles sont
au service de ma musique puis non c'est
pas vraiment un travail parce que le
seul travail que je vois dans ma vie
c'est celui de prendre un avion dont le
faire l'activité d'aller à l'aéroport de
laisser ma famille derrière pour aller
faire qu'est ce que j'ai mais qu'est ce
qui est ma passion
ça c'est la partie travail mais allez
sur cinq
répétez parler de projet agile il n'y a
pas de samedi apa dimanche c'est une
passion ça fait partie de ma vie si on
arrête sur bella jeudi puis alexandre da
costa
merci mille fois merci beaucoup oubliez
pas votre violon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]